the coroner presiding over the inquest
since the deaths of the London Bridge
tear attack victims has ruled that they
were unlawfully killed eight people died
in the space of just three minutes
nearly 50 were injured when three
attackers drove a van into crowds before
getting out and stabbing people who are
enjoying a Saturday night out the father
of one of the victims Alexander P guard
said despite inquest he still had many
questions about his son's death at the
end of this inquest concludes a
particularly long sequence of two years
to try despite the pain despite the
morning impossible to understand to
reconstruct the scene toboni to
understand to read all the documents put
to available by our team of lawyers to
watch and analyze all the CCTV footage
to edit it to search to learn to ask the
right question and hope for answers it's
over now and despite a rigorous
investigation I still don't know what
happened precisely to my son during the
first attack our home affairs
correspondent Mark white has been
listening to the evidence he joins us
now live from outside the Old Bailey
it's be a busy easy evening to say the
least mark and very difficult to listen
to some of that testimony from the
families of those killed yes it believed
families many of them do believe that
there is more that could have been done
to prevent that tragedy in 2017
intelligence feelings they see from
police and security services also the
lack of barriers on the bridge two
months after a similar terrorist attack
on Westminster Bridge and a big debate
about the need for barriers at iconic
sites and of course concerns about the
delay in getting ambulances right to the
heart of the scene where most of the
very seriously injured people where we
heard a short time ago from neil basu
who is the head of counterterrorism at
Scotland Yard reacting to the coroner's
remarks that
the eight people were unlawfully killed
but the police and security services he
said should not be held responsible for
missing signs of this emerging plot and
Neill pursue agreed with that saying
that there was only one group of people
to blame for the events at night this is
what he said protective security is a
collective responsibility and a
continuous work in progress
counterterrorism policing will continue
to work with our close partners
including the Home Office to improve
with regardless of the investigation
itself and with the benefit of hindsight
we know certain things could have been
done differently but after careful
consideration the Chief Coroner has
found that the Prayuth tech
investigation was nonetheless thorough
and rigorous